I want to know like what you see because
you come across a lot of like
entrepreneurs on every level
for the person that like wants to get
something going if you could attribute
it could if you could attribute their
success to three things what would it be
sure somebody that's uh uh maybe got a
side hustle who's an Uber driver
okay so so look you know the the first
thing you got to do is you got to ask a
very straight up question of yourself
okay
um
how much money you got in the bank
how much total net worth you have right
now what's the most you've ever had
before are you happy with those numbers
so if you said I got 28 grand in a bank
most I've ever had is 35 Grand
you know no I'm not happy with where I'm
at yeah and I'm willing to change so
then you got to ask yourself okay
if you're not happy with the results
today that means the way you process
issues doesn't produce the kind of
results you want so meaning your way of
thinking got you to have the life that
you have today okay so let's unpack your
way of thinking so I had a guy a friend
of mine that I used to party with a lot
so he would call me when I was trying to
make it and he had no desire to want to
make it this guy was a guy that wanted
to stay home and take care of his kid
and his wife would work I'm not that guy
I'm a guy that likes to work but that's
the life he chose to live I noticed
every time he would call me he was a
downer he was negative he was annoying
but I felt it was part of my duty to be
loyal to him because if I didn't I'm
being out of character and I felt guilt
that guilt got you to pick up the phone
call of a friend that every single time
about everybody so I would be on the
phone with them for 45 minutes it would
be about his wife he would about
his mom he would about his dad he
would about best friends he would
literally about everything and then I
knew when he got off the phone he's
going to call somebody else and he's
going to be about me I knew that for a
fact it's going to be taking place right
so finally one day I said listen do you
realize every time you call me it's bad
news I said Tommy the last time you call
me with good news and he says life isn't
always good man people got problems I
totally get it but I want you to tell me
last time you called me with some good
news I said moving forward I don't want
you to call me anymore really because
you drained me this is too much so how
do you train somebody that you don't
want to talk to anymore and it's once a
year when they call you let the phone
ring twice then you press end
you don't ignore it because they know
maybe they missed a call and if you
press end early they think you're in bad
reception area but if you wait two
seconds and then you press and they know
right you press send okay so then the
science behind me there's a science
behind it so you realize man either I
gotta be in the hunt to go after my
dreams or Pat's not going to want to
talk to me and honestly
I got over the whole guilt factor of
that yeah that I don't want to call and
don't want to talk to you if you're
constantly a downer a lot of times when
you're an Uber driver you're making
forty fifty sixty thousand dollars a
year people around you are making the
same kind of money as well it's not like
the people around you are making a
million two million five million 10
million it's it's challenging for you to
be friends with them because typically
one of two things will happen so let's
just say you make a million a year and
you're super disciplined you're after it
you're crushing it in life married kids
everything you're doing it's intentional
and I'm kind of like the guy we used to
play basketball in high school I was
your point guard you were the shooting
guard so we're boys we party together we
got history girlfriends all that stuff
we have that memory but now you're
married I'm still single okay so say you
call me on a Friday and I say Pat what
you got going on tonight I said nothing
it's man listen uh you got the Hawks are
playing Milwaukee and Trey's going
against Giannis man I got courtside
seats you want to go I said hell yeah
says dude I got tickets
six seats it's four grand a pop okay now
say I'm making fifty right and you're
making a meal yeah how am I gonna
receive that phone call when you call me
let's process that together one I'm
gonna say
you know I can't afford four grand four
tickets why are you calling me two I'm
gonna say I know you can afford it why
don't you pay for me
three
I'm just gonna make up some story to say
I'm busy but regardless of what it is
you're losing yeah not me
one
I'm going to inject guilt in you and why
are you calling me too if you don't pay
I'm gonna inject guilt again three I'm
gonna have to make up some story not to
go with you
or if I spend a four thousand dollars to
go with you I shouldn't do it because I
don't have that kind of money yeah so so
now you are afraid to call me next time
so there's only a matter like let's just
say Christmas my wife we want to create
family rituals this Christmas we want to
go to Aspen and we got this Cab in five
bedrooms we want you to bring your
family with you I'm like dude I can't
bring my family to you know let's put
the private jet let's go together man
it's only 100 Grand you do 50 I do 50.
this is not the fact that to you your
entire life is about money yeah and to
me my life isn't about money you've
taken those things a little bit more we
came from the same Hood we came from the
same high school we came from the same
we've seen the same drugs same Coke same
ecstasy same crack same pot same gang
send blood Craig blood diamond and it
doesn't matter we've seen the same thing
right
you changed the way you think I did not
all right listen every single week every
episode you hear me talking about
themorningmeetup.com it's the community
let me show you what's happening here
every single morning Monday through
Friday there's 400 plus people on a zoom
call right we're learning we're talking
we're growing together and this is you
there's all these people here it's all
these people in the morning meet up
hundreds of people reading books growing
we get together quarterly it's amazing
and for some reason you just keep
looking at
just go to themorningmail.com and get in
the circle and then you'll be like way
happier
just the morning meetup.com let's get
back to that episode so for people that
are in that situation let me tell you
what I did this week which was a very
special thing did you see the interview
I do with Antonio Brown I don't know if
you saw that I don't know that was next
on my YouTube so Tony Brown and I are
sitting together if you've seen it he
gets upset he says you idiot you don't
know what you're talking about he's
sitting right here where you're sitting
here like four weeks ago he was
seriously yeah he was serious so it's a
very very complicated interview with a B
so I said maybe you know uh so he says
you didn't come from the streets I came
from distress so listen my parents got a
divorce twice divorced family I came
from the Streets of L.A my dad was a
cashier in Inglewood California he said
where I grew up Liberty City people get
shot at I said what do you think happens
in Inglewood when my dad was working on
it so I grew up at Iran we got bombed on
he says no that's because you chose to
join the Army I said I didn't have a
choice I was born in Iran there's no
choice still right let me tell you what
happened he kept telling me about
Liberty City I said no problem you want
to create a paradigm ship for me I'll
accept it a b here's what I'm going to
do
on Wednesday
I tell my guys I want to go to Liberty
City so I go to Liberty City and I go to
find a Winn-Dixie in Liberty City we go
to that Winn-Dixie right across the
street there's a shooting bodies on the
ground cops are picking up the body stop
and we have this video you'll see it
that not that day that hour that's what
we're talking about I go to Liberty City
the manager of Liberty City
I tell them I want to be a bagger so I'm
wearing the outfit of a bagger I got the
picture right here for you I'm dressed
as a bagger at Liberty City Winn-Dixie
is what I'm doing okay I get in there
and this is me right here I get in there
that's me I'm a bad girl Winn-Dixie
you'll see the whole video me and
Heather that's Heather Heather's a
cashier right right there and I'm doing
the backing stuff yeah people are coming
by so say Hey Yolanda how you doing good
is that your son yes how old is he five
months hey Ma where's the diapers do we
need that oh we need diaper we can't
afford it right now what else the
diapers I go to Alpha pick up all the
diapers I bring him to them for an hour
on aisle number seven I was paying
everyone's groceries wow I said hey
Merry Christmas 280. Merry Christmas 3
20. and then people started realizing go
to aisles
but the entire time one of the ladies I
think was 85 years old she says who are
you so I'm just a regular guy she says
no you're not that's I'm telling you I'm
just a regular guy why are you doing
this I said why am I doing this yeah I
said because you said you're 85 she says
yes I said okay you were a teacher for
42 years I was
I said my dad did this for 15 years in
Inglewood he got held up three times
every time he got held up he would give
him the Bible and he would talk about
God with them eventually they loved my
dad because they he treated everybody
like regular people he wasn't afraid of
gangsters and he didn't see the drug as
a bad person he just talked to the
people and he would constantly figure
out a way to get close to them I said my
dad's 80 my dad's standing right there
my dad's standing right behind me while
he's watching me doing this okay
sometimes in life we need a paradigm
shift if you're rich you need to take
your kids to a place to see how rough
life can be if you're poor you need to
go look at a three million dollar home
with a realtor you need to go to a
Ferrari dealership you need to go to a
land I remember rights to go to a
Ferrari dealership David and I would say
I played one game here's what my game
was a sick game I would play I'm broke I
got nothing in my name I'm so poor it
sucks I'm about to go back in the Army
but I would say I want to find that if
they believe I'm rich I want to see if
this Ferrari sells for some beliefs I
can afford to buy a Ferrari so I would
go to the dealership and I would walk
around you know what I would say man the
guys ignore he doesn't even say hi you
know why he knows I can't afford it he
feels the vibe so a year later I would
go back in still doesn't talk to me year
later I go back in how are you good I
still can't afford it but now he
believes I can't afford it that's all
that matters so then I would go to my
hall and drive and I won one time to
look at this three and a half million
dollar house open house I walk in said
how you doing good
um what can you tell me about this
property and she leaves a customer and
comes with me and spends 45 minutes
showing the home this is at a time that
it can only probably buy 700 000
property but the fact that she thought
and believed my aura my energy was a
character of somebody that could afford
to buy three and a half million dollar
house it made me believe that I'm on my
way to be able to buy a three and a half
million dollar house so today I live in
a 30 million dollar house I don't don't
now it's a different story but during
that time stuff somebody that's driving
the Uber car right now you got to create
the other kind of Paradigm shifts for
you wow you got to go to a completely
different environment to get yourself to
say why not me why not my family why
can't I do something about it so if
you're doing Uber you can no longer I
went on a diet of music you know people
talking about hip-hop I don't know Lamar
the other day I was asking guys who are
the top five rappers right now one guy
said little baby's number one this
person is number 10 they're going back
and forth debating right you know who I
know
I know up until 2003 2002 because I went
on a radio diet yeah I've never I've not
turned on the radio since 2002. wow you
tell me any RMB if you want to play the
game of r b I can tell you wrong every
time I see
I can tell you Uncle Sam I don't ever
want to see you I can go to Brian
McKnight you know I can go to you know
Atlantics I can go to as yet I can go to
you know anything with Tupac anything
with big yeah I can go to one of the
greatest albums of all time by DMX I can
go more Murder By Bone Thugs and Harmony
I think it's number 16. I can go to I
can go to Black streets album tell you
exactly which one is the baby making
music to listen to you know don't leave
me I can go to Usher tell you my way I
can go to all of that stuff but my
timeline ends at O2 yeah because if
you're an Uber driver and you're serious
about your dreams
go on a radio die for one year no radio
for you this year nothing no radio no
Spotify the only thing you listen to all
your this year is audiobooks if you're
an Uber driver all business all
intentional All Vision all
autobiographies let people inspire you
can the person that's listening to this
right now making 50k you're saying Pat
David I'm ready I'm committed no problem
can you go on a Spotify
on an iTunes on a diet nothing for an
entire year now when you work out listen
to your hip hop fire yourself about
listen to hit up hit them up when I'm
working out I listen to my hip-hop music
when I'm working out because it's
getting me going
but I went on a radio diet since O2
tilted I've never once listened to the
radio so those are the things that the
exchanges people need to make to have a
paradigm shift and this is coming from a
guy that had a 1.8 GPA in high school
I'm not the guy that you know came out
of a family that I'm supposed to be
somebody so that's what I would say to
those folks
[Music]